[Musique]
bonjour yan monplaisir donc aux morilles
le temps bonjour à tous vos auditeurs
vice président de l'assemblée de
martinique chef de file de la droite au
sein du grand ensemble et houba payant
chance hier montplaisir le 5 octobre
dernier vous aviez pousser une gueulante
dans le bureau de le d'alfred
marie-jeanne plus dire ce qui vous
semblait être quelques vérités en deux
mots ce que la majorité fait n'est pas
assez visible et dans tous les cas est
suffisant point que la confiance a
disparu
question ce matin à montplaisir alfred
marie-jeanne et vous avez vous commencé
à rectifier le tir et vous mettre au
travail pour le développement du pays
judith d'abord pousser des gueulantes
même si quelquefois je suis un peu vif
le le sujet me semble suffisamment grave
pour que l'on ne polémique pas là dessus
par ailleurs ce que je nous avons voulu
c'est sensibiliser effectivement le
président sur ce que nous souhaitions
nous voulons aller plus vite et plus
loin
je pense qu'en ce faute que ce faisant
nous répondons à une sentiment que en
tout cas moi je ressens quel sentiment
profond que les martiniquais mais
exprime quand je les rends compte quand
je discute avec eux c'est un sentiment
je dirais d'impatience parce qu'il ya
deux logiques qui c'est qui
s'affrontaient alfred marie jeanne qui
berce dans l'excès de rigueur parce
qu'il faut assainir les comptes
car selon lui il ya eu un laisser-aller
grave et vous qui pensez qu'ils ne sont
pas restés paralysés pour autant
absolument je pense d'abord que presque
deux ans bientôt seront passées et que
nous avons trouvé une situation
budgétaire compliqué effectivement avec
un certain nombre de choses qui
n'apparaissaient pas dans les comptes de
la collectivité et qui étaient des
engagements rire est la formule pas dans
les gens se sera pas un mot de passe
coup tout excuser absolument bien
remplie ce jeudi il y à des difficultés
budgétaires serrées l on sait que l'état
à lui-même à régler un certain nombre de
problèmes et que donc il y à des
restrictions budgétaires qui nous sont
imposées comme aux autres collectivités
mais dans le même temps il faut que nous
continuons à mener une action de
développement de la martinique
c'est ce que je souhaite le les autres
régions et territoires d'outre-mer le
fond alors comment la boîte de café
touba panache un yacht et primat a été
primé les qui nous et il arrive à faire
des projections budgétaires qui sont des
programmes vous voulez des prochains
pour la martinie moi je veux je veux non
seulement des projets je veux qu'on
mette en oeuvre
je veux effectivement ya un certain
nombre de choses par exemple je veux pas
qu'on me dise vraiment avancer des
projets alors que nous avons été csp qui
nous narguent comme une grosse verrue
immense sur le nez qui renvoie alors les
capacités de l'ensemble de la classe
politique martiniquaise tous bords
confondus tout tous paliers confondus
on ne sait pas faire vous avez vous avez
raison évacuer rapidement la sphère du
tcsp parce qu' il faudrait faire une
émission spéciale c'est maintenant ça ne
marche pas non monsieur ce n'est pas ça
l'idée l'idée c'est qu'il faudrait faire
une émission si vous met vite et dans un
débat je suis prêt à venir et j'ai donné
ma position je pense que il faut qu'on
sorte de cette paralysie qui résulte
d'abord de manque de dialogue
et le constat la réalité c'est quoi
c'est qu'en fait tout avait été fait
pour que serge letchimy redevienne
président de la collectivité n'est pas
le match je vous explique simplement
aujourd'hui ce qui devrait financer
l'opération au moins en partie
c'est à dire le syndicat la casse elles
n'ont pas d'argent et donc on est devant
cette situation et vous parlez de thaon
les vosges alors qu'il n'y a pas
d'argent
permettez moi il faut être réaliste
aujourd'hui ces collectivités n'ont pas
d'argent
serge letchimy pensé qu'il serait
président de la région il allait tout
faire financer par la région il est
logique que le président de la région de
la collectivité aujourd'hui se disent
qu' il n'a pas à tout financer mais
malheureusement je crains qu'on en
arrive à cette extrémité
parce que il faut être réaliste et que
cet outil qui a coûté près de 80 480
millions d'euros
et là et qu'il faut qu'ils roulent pour
quelques kilomètres on que vous voyez
afrique on va rester pendant un quart
d'heure dessus je vous laisse le ca c
est fixé lettres des sciences le tcsp
c'est une chose c'est un échec
c'est un constat d'échec il y à un
manque de dialogue il y ait un manque de
réalisme
il y à un manque de concertation et à
mon avis il faudrait changer les
interlocuteurs pour faire en sorte que
dans une grande objectivité on arrive à
une solution
yan monplaisir le mariage civil à
l'humanité le main ou pour le débat
politique il faudrait déjà vous adresser
à l'ensemble de vos la presse politique
multi veulent entraîner la mort
du débat si vous avez ça c'est pas gagné
alors je suis prêt alors il ya une
piscine le mariage de la carpe et du
lapin en train de frais de marie-jeanne
bon père de famille du très bon
gestionnaire et vous qui voulez aller
plus vite avant il n'y a pas d'argent
timonen préfet mais ce que vous avez
enlevé il ya un moment où il ne faut pas
est ce que j'ai trouvé quelque chose qui
pourrait vous reprocher frais de marie
jeanne et vous sur ce site
si vous me permettez de 2,2 de terminer
ce n'est pas le mariage de la carpe et
du lapin
c'est le mariage c'est le mariage de
deux mouvements politiques de deux
leaders politiques qui avait le souci de
préserver la démocratie à la martinique
moi c'est ce qui m'a guidé j'avais le
sentiment que nous aurions basculer dans
une forme d'autoritarisme pour ne pas
utiliser un autre terme qui
s'approcherait de ce que vit
actuellement le venezuela est donc aulas
est donc oui et donc et donc permettra
non monsieur merci vous en laissez pas
dit mais ne laissez pas développer mes
idées je n'y arriverai pas a lire et
donc donc donc c'est ce que j'ai fait
quelle est l'idée qu'il ya derrière sa
part ailleurs alfred marie-jeanne c'est
vrai on sait que c'est un homme de
rigueur mais on ne peut pas simplement
quand on est président d'une cote d'une
collectivité est un comptable
il faut donc une projection et ce
qu'attendent de nous les martiniquais
c'est que nous leur disions ce que nous
avons l'intention de faire
quand je dis par exemple on ne peut pas
répondre qu'il ya pas d'argent pour
reconstruire pour construire le pont sur
la rivière des pères c'est une évidence
quand je dis qu'il faut qu'on ait un
projet pour que mon désastre fixie toute
cette zone de circulation qui va de
fort-de-france à rivière salée
c'est une évidence pour ce qu'ils vivent
c'est une évidence pour le développement
économique
quand je dis qu'il est temps de porter
au moins de faire des études pour faire
en sorte que l'on relit les zones
d'activités entre elles les zones vertes
et l'udr c
oui parce qu'il faut d'abord faire des
études mais fond il faut d'abord arrêter
le principe de faire des études si vous
ne fait même pas les études monsieur
monsieur violon c'est que vous n'avez
pas l'intention de faire alors il faut
lancer tout de suite on peut lancer tout
de suite donc en novembre 2010 s'est
toujours pas d'étude donc ya pas d
intention de fermer non attendez je vous
parle de quelque chose de précis je ne
pars pas en général
le constat que nous devons faire que
font les martiniquais c'est qu'il y ait
une
ils viennent pas
dans le secteur du bâtiment free jeanne
mance et non sur cet aspect qui faut
lancer les études
j'espère qu'elle qu'il m'attend et je
crois qu'il entend ici il ne m'entend
pas je le répèterai il faut pas que j'ai
pas parlé seulement d'études je vous
parle de lancer aussi immédiatement un
certain nombre de travaux par exemple il
y à la nécessité de nous mettre aux
normes sur le plan sismique
il y à la nécessité d'améliorer le
réseau des eaux de distribution d eau et
il n'y a et il ya besoin de soutenir les
collectivités qui sont porteuses de ces
projets là comme espace sud ou cap nord
parcequ'elle gens voudraient s'installer
de nouveau toute façon elle est entendue
je sais pas si c'est nouveau ici on l'a
déjà entendu mais encore fallait-il de
faire monsieur viol tension n'en parlez
vous réceptionnez si on en parle encore
aujourd'hui mais c'est pour ça que j'en
parle
si on en parle encore aujourd'hui c'est
bien parce que il y a nécessité de
mettre en oeuvre cette politique pour
que le bâtiment soit relancé par exemple
je vais vous dire on a lancé un fonds
d'investissement
c'est très bien mais ce n'est pas avec
un million d'euros que l'on va régler le
problème des besoins de financement des
entreprises
il faut être plus ambitieux que cela et
je lui dis à l'exécutif
il y a la possibilité et permettez moi
d'aller au bout de ma pensée il y a la
possibilité de mobiliser des fonds
européens à travers un dispositif qui
s'appelle les fonds sofia de manière
significative les typhas compris
l'équation du fonds européen
je pense qu'il a compris avec l'équation
mais qu' il y a eu un peu en retard à
l'allumage qui qui est dûe à la
réorganisation qui était indispensable
quand nous sommes arrivés aux affaires
les chefs d'entreprise nous on dit ça ne
marche pas tout est bloqué il y à un
machin qui s'appelle brigitte changé ils
en changent on a changé de chef
d'entreprise parce qu'ils continuent à
dire que ça ne fonctionne pas il
ils ont raison de le dire parce qu'ils
sont ils ont raison d'être impatients
les chefs d'entreprise il veut se
projeter ils veulent savoir où nous
allons et comment nous allons y aller et
moi ce que je veux dire
et là où il y avait effectivement une
divergence de fond entre nous c'est que
il
ils ont ne peut pas dire à la martinique
on ne peut pas dire aux chefs
d'entreprises nous piquer fait rien
céder au trio vie des cas cela ce qui
est en partie vrai mais c'est pour ça
qu'il conte a été élu il a été élu pour
corriger cela il ya mon plaisir au
moment d'embrasser la mariée en décembre
on ne connaissait pas son caractère bien
sûr que je connaissais son caractère
c'est pour ça que je me suis appelé
monsieur fioles ton vous avez raison
parce que moi quand je regarde une
réalité quand je vois mon pays souffrir
quand je vois mon peuple la population
de la martinique souffrir quand je vois
qu'il ya des risques pour la martinique
eh bien je ne fais pas comme d'autres je
ne me contente pas de parler je vais
dans l'action parce que je considère que
j'ai le tempérament j'ai peut-être c'est
très modestement chacun sa vision et je
peux être critiqué mais en tout cas moi
une jeune élu territorial tout se passe
au conseil exécutif
la structure système a été fait que le
système a été fait comme ça mais je
pense qu'avec de la bonne volonté on
peut le corriger
le président c'est vrai qu'il par
exemple la collectivité l'assemblée
l'assemblée n'a pas de budget
si le président le veut on trouvera un
dispositif faut faire en sorte que
l'assemblée vous rendez compte que pour
commander une feuille de papier
le président de l'assemblée claude lise
est obligé de s'en référer à l'exécutif
c'est comme ça que la loi a été conçue
et bien il faut que nous attendions des
amendements et des corrections de tout
cela mais que nous soyons pratiques que
nous soyons très pratique merci d'avoir
atterri ce matin avec notamment plaisir
vice président david marty d'une bonne
journée
d